your starting pitcher for the
diamondbacks today the right-hander luke
weaver
last outing pretty good so we're hoping
he can build on that and take it into
tonight's ball game
jammed him that time with another heater
and ahmed cleans it up good start a one
two three first for luke weaver kohei
arihara making the start today it'll be
his ninth start of the season martay
hitting 331 10 homer's 40 rbi as the
switch hitter he went over three on a
walk yesterday swing in the miss he got
him up and in with a fastball two up and
two down and then meter coming up next
and that'll be an easy play for
tavares and it's a 12 pitch first inning
for arihara dj peters leads off the
rangers second
peters is a dangerous hitter 10 home
runs
and he finally wore him down with that
changeup big deep breath there from luke
weaver you're in that strikeout that's
his first boy just a great pitch down in
the strike zone here you see it right
out of his hand to change up grip and it
just dives down into the ground 86 miles
an hour his circle change i love that
seeing that rotation
261 and seven home runs oh for four from
the cleanup spot last night
peralta drives it deep to right field
david peralta say goodbye
that's number eight for the freight
train diamondbacks have a one-nothing
lead
[Music]
gonzo we've talked about this during the
game yesterday peralta if you go back to
early last month has really had a
tremendous last 30 games or so yeah and
i think this is the peralta that they
were hoping for at the start of the
season here you see a just a flat slider
right there on over the outer half of
the plate and he just jumped all over
and he knew he got it when he hit it
that's a no doubter well over the head
of garcia and right
and an early lead for luke weaver here
is henry ramos his first ever major
league start
and he's got another base hit
punches the cutter down the left field
line henry ramos in right field
that's career hit number two in start
number one here's the bar show now
dalton sends it out to left field peters
hits off the glove rommel's had to wait
up a minute he'll come in and score
and the diamondbacks take a two-nothing
lead
that's a double at an rbi for dalton
varshall as dj peters out there in left
field got all kinds of crossed up here
boy just a nice piece of hitting
by marshall and peters makes a nice
effort there
[Music]
it looked like he got a late break on
the ball
and we almost went to make sure it gets
down he scores easily two-nothing
diamondbacks army guys
diamond banks will play the infield at
normal depth here with a two-nothing
lead the rangers have had trouble in the
past it's been in these types of
situations where they get a guy on base
maybe scoring position to start an
inning and can't get him in but their
little chopper third base that will get
it done kind of brings tavares to the
plate on the ground out and it's a 2-1
ball game and now here's lowe who lying
down to peralta and left his first timer
one strike pitch peters with a bluff and
this one lined over first that's a base
hit and into the corner nobody home out
there peters with good speed he'll round
third and score heading for third is low
and he's in there with a triple
he has tied the game at two
with his third
triple of the season the o2 pitch to
solac
chopper short stop on the run ahmed the
throne not in time
solac beats it out and the rangers take
their first lead of the game we've
talked about this all year long the
hustle from nick solak and how well he
gets down the line
and it shows up here in a big way we
know ahmed's very good over there at
shorty did a good job on the exchange
but you can see there clearly that nick
solak beats that infield single out to
scratch another run across the board for
the rangers we did a comparison
yesterday we mentioned this to you as
you take one more look here nick solak
getting in safely bases loaded in the
fourth inning here today six runs and
nine hits oh two on ari harp weaver into
the wind and the pitch and he got him
swinging
on the breaking ball the ending finally
comes to an end but they bat around
three runs score they leave the bases
loaded varsha with third base rojas at
first base two outs in the bottom of the
fifth dennis santana has come on in this
fifth inning for the rangers and to the
plate and there's a line shot to center
field tavares to his left is right there
he's got it one pitch and santana gets
the job done no runs a hit two left nick
solac and jake faria turned into quite
an odyssey here pitch number 16 in the
at-bat
on the way
it stays in fair territory for van meter
got a hurry
and solace boy did he earn that one yes
he did
zolac got up that line pretty well
a 16-pitch infield single for nick solac
won one pitch
and there's a bouncer left side of the
infield that indeed could be two it will
not though they will take the one out at
second base no throw even offered to
first
so low scores and the rangers have a 4-2
lead men on the corners pozo will hit
here love to add a little more to their
lead imposa with a big swing that ball
hit well deep out to left and it's off
the fence
solac is in trevino to third they'll
stop in there on the double
by pozo and it's 5-2
well he just missed fastball it came
back a little bit they were looking to
go away that one tailing in it looked
like he thought he got it and
unfortunately came up just a little bit
short a couple of feet more and that's a
homer but he picks up the rbi the
rangers extend that lead now it's five
to two two minutes scoring position and
the diamondbacks go deeper into that
bullpen out of the stretch checks are
under at second the pitch
and a line drive that's caught by van
meter
to end the ending well that was a big
play right there
as he took a hit away and that would
have scored a couple more it's 5-2 texas
peralta had a big home run earlier today
he's one for two
bouncer back up the middle diving stop
and the flip to second not in time
nobody home at third base johnny
hernandez takes off and the rangers are
going to challenge his play it could be
a little bit confusing you have
basically two guys going toward the bag
zolac is there about so like catching
that ball and he is out
but how about solace that's a great view
he caught that ball and he was not
looking at it
on the flip here from isaiah counterfeit
he takes his eye look at that wow
christian walker seven home runs couple
injuries
and there it is under the glove of
hernandez peralta will score that extra
90 feet
leads to a diamondbacks run the rvi for
christian walker
and it's five to three
first time in a big league mound he was
pitching an independent ball just two
years ago but has put up some tremendous
strikeout numbers 51 punch-outs in 38
innings between amarillo and reno this
year
nick comet is there
three ground ball outs welcome to the
big leagues brandon sittinger we stretch
a chase it's five free texas trevino get
these runners home here base hit would
score two
2-0
and that one out to center field that's
a base hit
in comes low
solac right behind him a two-run single
by trevino
and the rangers make it a 7-3 game in
the eighth inning
slow roller up the middle that's a tough
play isaiah beats it out
and
one run has scored we're not gonna have
a run down between
third base and the plate martin
pretty amazing if he survives it he does
not and the inning is over but the
rangers do have a run nick ahmed 0 for
3.
comet hits one deep to left field and
that's going to go a home run for nick
is fifth of the year and hold the phone
we're not done yet
nick gets a 89 mile an hour fastball up
in the strike zone right where he likes
it
you know the more he lays off those
breaking balls down the more he sees
those fast balls up and those are the
ones he can get in the air to his pull
side
drives it to right garcia will have to
play it off the wall rojas will score
it's a long rbi
for could tell martay and it's eight to
five
and it's one ball and one strike
low
makes the play and this one is over and
barlow
does slam the door in the ninth
rangers with an 8-5 win to sweep this
series in arizona barlow gets the save
the rangers win it eight to five and
they have equal their longest winning
streak of the season at four